all right he's embarking on a 40 city
speaking saw for his new book 12 rules
for life
an antidote to chaos here's a clip from
this channel 4 interview that went viral
earlier this year why should your right
to freedom of speech
trump a trans person's right not to be
offended
because in order to be able to think you
have to risk being offensive
i mean look at the conversation we're
having right now you know like you're
certainly willing to risk offending me
in the pursuit of truth
why should you have the right to do that
it's been rather uncomfortable
please welcome jordan peterson
[Music]
professor
hey great pleasure to meet you how you
doing
i'm a big fan as you might have like as
you might have guessed and i love what
you just said that
in order to be able to think you have to
risk
being offensive and that went viral that
made you very famous
why do you think that sparked such a
reaction
well because i think that what i was
saying was self-evidently true but not
expressed very well very often i mean
look
most of the time when you're discussing
something that needs to be discussed
everybody's actually rather upset about
it you know if you're actually talking
about something important right because
why talk otherwise
unless you're just shooting the breeze
but if there's an issue at hand that has
to be discussed and
people are already upset and they have
different viewpoints and
and the the the offensiveness in some
sense is built into that
and you know that because if you have a
family if you have a wife if you have an
intimate relationship
and you're discussing something that's
difficult the probability that you're
not going to offend each other
if you're actually having the
conversation is zero
and so you don't have to think unless
you have a problem
and if you have a problem then when you
think you're going to offend people
and so what are we not going to think
that seems like a bad idea
no um yeah
you're obviously not an american
we love to not think but
but you know i used to do a show called
politically incorrect back in the 90s
and
uh oh thank you oh the 90s we remember
them
and so i was always asked what is your
definition of political correctness and
i would i
had to come up with one i said it's the
elevation of sensitivity over truth
which seems like what it still is except
it's worse than ever
like that it's more like the elevation
of moral posturing about sensitivity
over truth it's even worse
yeah so where did it come from why did
we get how did we get to this place
where we're so fragile the safe space
people
oh i think i think that you can pretty
much blame it on the universities
i think that they've pursued uh
especially in the humanities and
and in the social sciences as well
they've pursued a policy of
a radical leftist policy with an overlay
of post-modernism which kind of a
literary criticism
uh approach that's produced all of this
as far as i can tell
i think you can lay a lot of it at the
feet of faculties like the faculties of
education
there was an article in the chronicle of
higher education this week just that
just just devastated the faculties of
education taking them to task for
low academic standards and for
possession by ideology and for
and for and for basically indoctrinating
people in a cult like manner and playing
identity politics and group
identity and no free speech they don't
seem to
there was an incident in fresno state i
don't know if you saw this but
barbara bush died okay some
professor there tweeted something nasty
yeah i wouldn't have tweeted it she
called barbara bush a racist and said
she raised
war criminals okay you know it's it's
yeah well the timing this crowd likes it
but but i mean
it's it's nasty and and she's uh they're
considering suspending her and here's
what the president of the university
said
he said this was beyond free speech this
was disrespectful
have we have we lost the thread back to
knowing what free speech is yes it can
be disrespectful
that is covered under free speech
president of fresno
idiot jesus christ
yeah well and you see you see this too i
i think
where it's manifesting itself in a
particularly appalling manner is in the
increasing on um unwillingness of
comedians for example to go on
university campuses to be funny
and when comedians yeah well exactly
exactly
yeah [ __ ] them i mean i'm not gonna i i
i call these people emotional
hemophiliacs
you know it's like the least little
thing will make them start to bleed but
it makes me cause
they're their answer
is not to go into a room full of sharp
objects
the answer is to make all of us wear
bubble wrap
yeah right so nothing we ever do makes
them have a moment of discomfort
well there's there's also this idea
that's promoted by the people who are
protecting those who are easily offended
that the way to make people secure is to
protect them from things that they don't
want to encounter and
there isn't a clinician like i'm a
trained clinical psychologist and there
isn't a clinician in the country who's
worth his or her assault that would ever
make that claim
because you don't make people first of
all it's hard to make people safe
because life is seriously not safe
yes and the way that you make the way
that you make people
resilient is by exposing them to things
that they're afraid of and that make
them uncomfortable voluntarily but
you use exposure right and it's a
and so like if you if you over coddle
people if you protect them from
everything that's sharp you make them
dull and stupid and
and and narcissistic and it's a really
bad idea
so you do know america
um one thing i mean your book is
fantastic and one of the rules that i
really love is you say don't let your
kids
do anything that would make you not like
them
that's what i i've been thinking for
years when i call them the [ __ ] you mom
generation when i
when i see kids never in life because i
never go near a child but
but like on tv and movies i see kids
like saying [ __ ] you mom
if somebody who wasn't your child did
that you'd be immensely offended whereas
the parents just
take it what's up with that well people
people don't like to admit that they can
dislike
their children or children in general
and
right no i
i know what you mean and i think they
can
no they totally can one of the things
you see very commonly as a as a clinical
psychologist
is families who family members who hate
each other
and who it's like they have their hands
around each other's necks for 20 years
and are squeezing very slowly trying to
strangle each other
and so and you see parents who clearly
detest their children and have ever
since they were born and
part of that i know it's a terrible way
of looking at things but it's true
it's so true and one of the things what
no parents can find that in me because i
don't have kids
yeah well no that makes it safe
no but they say things like yeah i love
my kids but if i had to do it over again
i wouldn't
yeah well like well don't tell the kid
that well so that but that's so bad
it is so bad because the thing is about
about little kids is
is that little kids have a have a
wonderful element to them
and if they and most people
spontaneously like little kids they'll
give them a chance and if you have
little kids one of the things that's so
wonderful about it is that when you
bring them out into the world even
people who are aren't in good shape
rough people and who who maybe don't
have much patience for humanity
it brings out the best in them you know
and so people are willing to give your
kids a chance
but then if they misbehave especially if
they're rude and
and they don't have any respect and
they're whiny and they don't know how to
listen
then people don't like your kids and you
don't and then the kids
your kids go out into a world where no
one likes them and that's what you
well that's what you do to your kids if
you don't like them unless you send them
out into that world
but right but but how did how did
parents get so
pussy-whipped by the by their own
children
i mean that's really what it is i mean
it's it's like they act the way a guy
acts when he's super sprung on some
chick and
just lets her walk all over him and
whatever she does he puts up with i i
don't get how
how we got to that well i think parents
are afraid of exercising authority
because they tend to think that
authority will crush the creative spirit
of their child
no [ __ ] well that is
[Laughter]
yeah yeah okay
no i i see everything this man says i
think is common sense
he said you guys should have a baby
together yeah we should have a baby
together
it's like it's like we get crucified for
what we say i don't think anything we
say is controversial at all
it's hard do you think he's
controversial i just had a kid
it's hard figuring it out and by the way
everyone is neurotic that's why we have
a hard time raising children
the right way because we live in the
most neurotic insane over connected
crazy world
donald trump is our president right now
we expected to raise normal children
it's a crazy time